وعملا بالماده 39 من النظام الداخلي
المؤقت لمجلس الامن ادعوا مقدمه الاحاطه
التاليه اسمائهم الى المشاركه في هذا
الاجتماع
السيد فولكررتس الممثل الخاص للعميل العام
المعني بالسودان
ورئيس بعثه الامم المتحده المتكامله
لتقديم المساعده خلال الفتره الانتقاليه
في السودان
صاحب السعاده
الافريقي
للشؤون السياسيه والسلام والابناء وصاحب
السعاده وركنه
الامين التنفيذي للسلطه الحكوميه الدوليه
المعنيه بالتنميه تقرر ذلك
سيبدا مجلس الامن الان
النظر في البند الثاني من جدول العمل
وجهه عنايه اعضاء مجلس الامن الى الوثيقه
s شارطه 2023 شارطه 355
وهي تقري الامين العام عن الحاله في
السودان وعن انشطه بعثه الامم المتحده
المتكامله لتقديم مساعده خلال الفتره
الانتقاليه في السودان
اعطي الكلمه الان للسيد بلكرديس شكرا
جزيلا سيدتي
الساده اعضاء مجلس الامن
[موسيقى]
من اعلانات وقف اطلاق ينار المتكرره
السابقه من الطرفين لم نشهد يوما بدون
قتال ولم يستطع طرف من الطرفين
اعلنا انتصار حاسم على الطرف الاخر وهنا
الاتفاق على وقف اطلقنا القصير المدى
والترتيبات الانسانيه والذي تم التوقيع
عليه منذ يومين في جده يعد خطوه هما نحو
الامام ويعطي املا للمدنيين
ويظهر ان العنف يمكن ان ينتهي
اذا امتثل الطرفان
وساعود الى هذا في نهايه حديثي الموجز
المدنيون في السودان دفعوا بالفعل ثمنا
باهظا بسبب هذا العنف غير المبرر ووفقا
لتقديرات اكثر من 700 شخص قتلوا بما في
ذلك اكثر من 190 طفل
واصيب سته الاف اخرون من المدنيين
والكثيرون مفقودين واكثر من مليون تم
تشريدهم واكثر 840 الف شخص ساعه الى الريف
او الى
واكثر او حوالي 250 الف
عبروا الحدود الى دول المجاوره وحوالي
8000 من المشردين من النساء الحوامل
يبحثون عن الامن والامن وكثيرون انتظروا
عند الحدود اياما واسابيع
وما من هذه الاحصاءات تظهر المعاناه
لكثرين اخرين لم يستطيعوا الرحيل وبقوا في
ديارهم
بامدادات تنفذ وبدون الحصول على مساعدات
وانا ممتن للبلدان التي تستقبل اللاجئين
في السودان من السودان ومن الامر الحيوي
ان تبقى الحدود مفتوحه لمن يطلب الامان ان
الاجراءات عند الحدود
ينبغي ان يتم تعديلها ولون المتحده تواصل
توفير دعمها لتخفيف العبء على الدول
المجاوره ولضمان تلبيه احتياجات اللاجئين
بكرامه
سيدتي الرئيسه في الخرطوم وفي دارفور وفي
مناطق اخرى الاطراف المتناحره حاربوا
محدوده للقوانين والمعايير المنازل
والمتاجر وبدور العباده
والمرافق الاساسيه من مياه وكهرباء تم
تدميرها وقطاع الصحه ينهار واكثر من ثلاثي
المستشفيات اغلقه وكثير من العاملين بمجال
الصحه قتلوا والامدادات الطبيه تنفذ وهناك
بلاغات متكرره عن استخدام مرافق الصحه كم
مواقع عسكريه وهذا غير مقبول وانا
ازازته بتقارير عنا العنف الجنسي ضد
المراه والفتاه بما في ذلك دعائه اغتصاب
في الخرطوم وفي دارفور والامم المتحده
تتابع للتحقق من هذه الحالات الاطراف
المتناحره ينبغي ان تمنع اي اعاده تكرار
لهذا العنف الاطفال يواجهون
مشاغل حمايه خطيره ويعرضون للتجنيد وللعنف
ضد الجنسي وللاختطاف وهناك بلاغات متكرره
عن انتشار النهدي للمنازل وللشركات
واستفزاز وتحرش
واختفاء القصريه
والمقرات الامميه بما في ذلك مجمع البعثه
تم النهبها كذلك
[موسيقى]
ومما يعقد المشهد اطلاق صلاح الالفي
السجناء
وانتشار الاسلحه الخفيفه وما يقلقني كذلك
بلاغاتى عنا تهديد بقتل ضد النشاطئ
السياسيين والقيادات المدنيه واعتقال
المتطوعين واستفزاز الصحفيين اصحاب
السعاده في بعض انحاء البلاد
القتال القتال بين الجيشين او التشكيلتين
المسلحتين ادى الى اندلاع
توتر قبلي واثني وفي الجنينه في غرب
دارفور الاشتباكات بين القوات المسلحه
السودانيه والقوات الدعم السريع تحولت الى
عنف اثني قبلي يوم 24 من ابريل
مش ميليشيات القبليه انضمت الى القتال
وحمل المدنيون السلاح للدفاع عن انفسهم
المنازل والاسواق
والمستشفيات حرقت ونهبت المطارات الامم
المتحده واكثر من 450 مدنيه قتلوا واكثر
من 700 اصيبوا يوم الثاني عشر من مايو
تجدد العنف
وادى الى سقوط اكثر من 200 قتيل وعشرات
الالاف من المشاردين الذين فروا الى تشاد
والحاله
صعبه جدا وادعو واحث على التهدئه وهناك
اسباب قلق تتعلق بالبعد القبليه في جنوب
كردفان وفي منطقه النيل الازرق والقتال
ادى الى انتها حقوق انسان خطيره وانتهاكات
القانون الانساني الدولي وقد اضر بحمايه
المدنيين وهذه الانتهاكات ينبغي ان تخضع
للتحقيق وينبغي للجناء ان يقدموا للعداله
اسره المتحده تواصل المتابعه والرصده
والدعوه من اجل انهاء كل انتهاكات
سداد المجلس
بعض المعلقين
القوا اللوم
بسبب هذا النزاع على المجتمع الدولي لانه
لم يرى علامات الانذار واخرون القوا
باللوم على العمليه السياسيه او على
الاتفاق الاطاري والذي كان الغرض منه ان
يؤدي الى حكومه مدنيه او القى اللوم على
المجتمع الدولي بسبب
اعطائي دور كبير مفرط في حجمه للمسلحين
ولكن دعونا نبتغي الوضوح المسؤوليه عن
القتال تقع على اعتاقه من يشن القتال
يوميا قيادات بالجانبين يتفقون في
المساءله والمسؤوليه بسبب اختيارهم حل
النزاع
بالعنف
بدلا من التفاوض القرار قرارهم
وقرار الانهاء بيديهم كذلك وما يحدث يوم
الخامس عشر من ابريل ومنذ ذلك اليوم هو
تحديدا محاوله المتحده وحاول دولي ان يمنع
حدوثه قبل وبعد ال 25 من اكتوبر 2021
وتاريخ الانقلاب العسكري
تواصلنا
باهتمام وبنشاط مع القائدين العسكريين
وحاولنا اقناعهم
بدعم الحمليه الانتقاليه نحو القياده حكم
المدني ومع زياده التوتر اطلقت ناقوس
الخطر في هذا المجلس في اذار مارس وحثثته
الاطراف على التهدئه وفي الاسبوعين سابقين
على اندلاع القتال انا وشركائي في الالياف
الثلاثيه
قمنا بتكثيف تواصلنا مع القيادات العسكريه
من اجل تهدئه الوضع وقمنا بتنسيق الجهود
مع القيادات المدنيه السودانيه وحاولنا
كذلك ان نتوسط بين
القيادات العسكريه واللوائين واقررت
بخطوره الموقف
وطلبت من الاطراف الاقليميه ان يستخدموا
نفوذهم مع الطرفين
واستمرت الجهود الى عشيه الخامس عشر من
ابريل حين ظننا اننا احرزنا تقدما
وانما استيقظنا وعلى واقع اختيار الحرب
سيدتي الرئيسه للاسف الاعمال العدائيه
تضطرنا
وتطردنا لان
ننقل موظفينا الى بورسودان والى خارج
السودان
وهذا ليس معناه وينبغي نكون واضحا جدا هنا
اننا تخلينا عن الشعب السوداني
اننا نواصل العمل مع شركاء السودانيين
واننا ثابتون في التزامنا
باربعه اولويات فوريه اولا
توصل الى وقف اطلاق نار مستقر باليه رست
ثانيا منع التصعيد او التحول القبلي لهذا
النزاع ثالثا حمايه المدنيين وتوفير
الاغاثه الانسانيه ورابعا الاستعداد
لعمليه سياسيه عندما يحين الوقت السليم
بمشاركه
واسعه من الجهات المدنيه والسياسيه بما في
ذلك النساء ومن خلال مركزنا في بورسودان
دعمت البعثه جهود الفريق القطري وشركاء
الانسانين من اجل استعاده تدفق الامدادات
الانسانيه الى داخل البلاد وفي انحاء
البلاد
وامم المتحده تبذل كل ما تستطيع للتوسع في
استجابتنا في انحاء البلاد ولا سيما في
مناطق الاحتياج الحاد ولكن من الضروري
كذلك في شرق البلاد
عند البحر الاحمر وحيث بورتسودان
انه فيها شرق البلاد لا تستغل المنطقه فقط
كمدخل للمساعدات الانسانيه ولكن ان تحصل
من تقع على نصيبها كذلك المنصف من
احتياجات علما بل لجوء كثيرين الى هذه
المنطقه التمويل الاضافي مطلوب
والخط خطه الاستجابه الانسانيه المعدله
اطلقت في سبعه عشره من مايو ويصل يصل مبلغ
الى 2.6 مليار دولار للوصول الى 18 مليون
شخص وهي زياده 15 مليون دولار عن قبل
القتال
واصحاب السعاده بفضل الوساطه السعوديه
والامريكيه ممثل الطرفين وقعوا على
اعلاني التزاماتي في جده في يوم الحادي
عشر من عيار مايو وهو اتفاق على ترتيبات
عمل انساني هو وقف اطلاق نار قصير المدى
والمفترض ان تدخل حيز النفاذ الليله
وستبقى في الساريه لسبعه ايام وقابله
للتجديد والمفترض ان تسمح بتحرك المدنيين
وبوصول المساعدات
وهذا تطور حميد نرحب به
ولكن القتال استمر حتى اليوم على الرغم من
التعاقد الطرفين بعدم محاوله احتياز
تفوق عسكري قبل دخول الاتفاقيه
وبعثتنا مستعده لدعم اليه رصد على المدى
البعيد ومن اجل رصد وقفه لقينار دائم
ويمكن ان نستند الى الهياكل التي انشات في
لجنه وقفه لقدر الدائمه في دارفور والتي
تراسها البعثه واحث الاطراف على احترام
هذا الاتفاق الذي تم التوقيع عليه منذ
يومين
عليهما ان يوقف القتال وان يسمحوا بوصول
الاغاثه وان يحموا العاملين الانسانيين
والممتلكات الانسانيه وان يسمحوا بالمرور
الامن للمدنيين ليرحلوا عن مناطق الاشتباك
واحث قياده القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وقياده القوات الدعم السريع
على ضمان حمايه المدنيين
والمباني المدنيه اننا ننفق عن كثب مع
شركاء السودانيين الذين يعملون من اجل
السلام واحيي كذلك قيادات الحركات المسلحه
على جهودهم لاستعاده السلام وعلى حيادهم
في هذا النزاع
المجتمع المدني السوداني يؤدي دورا قويا
في الدعوه من اجل السلام مع مواصله دعم
المدنيين هذه الجهود ينبغي ان تحظى بالدعم
والطرفان ابن كول
يدعواني
لادانه الطرف الاخر
وادانه افعاله وانا ادعو الطرفين الى
انهاء القتال والعوده الى الحوار لمصلحه
السودان وشعب السودان
الارواح والمباني تدمرت والبنيه تحتيه
تدمرت والبعد القبلي المتزايد لهذا
النزاعي يهدد
بطول النزاع وبتدعيات على المنطقه وان
وقفه القنار المتفق عليه يمكن له ان يمهد
الطريق وينبغي ان يفعل ذلك من اجل وقف
دائم للاعمال العدائيه
ومع تقدم المباحثات فهناك طائفه واسعه من
الجهات المدنيه والسياسيه التي ينبغي ان
تؤدي دورها وفي نهايه المطاف ليس الا
مرحله انتقاليه بقياده مدنيه ذات مصداقيه
هي التي سترسم طريق السلام الدائم
نائب مجلس السياده
النص على ان اولوياته هي وقف اطلاق النار
وانهاء الحرب واسكاتي المدافع وهذا بلا شك
يستحق دعمنا ودعمكم الكامل
الجهود الاقليميه والدوليه لانهاء القتال
في السودان تستحق الحمد وبعد تضاعف هذه
الجهود ينبغي ان نضمن التنسيق من اجل
تحديد نهج مشترك هذا سينهض
بتاثيرنا الجماعي وفعاليه الجهود اي خطه
منسقه ينبغي ان يشارك فيها جيران السودان
في المنطقه وانا مسرور جدا ان زميلي
المفوض بنكولي والامين التنفيذي دكتور برك
سيتحدثان وسيدخلاني في التفاصيل بشان جهود
الاليه الثلاثيه
وستواصل المتحده للعمل الوثيق مع الشركاء
في اطار هذه الاليه ثلاثيه وهما الاتحاد
الافريقي والهيئه الدوليه المعنيه
بالتنميه لايجاد دعما لهذه الجهود وجهود
الاخرين وشكرا
اشكركم سيبرتس على الاحاطه
وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات